gang the middle class famous store is
about to kick in the high gear baby
we're talking about a fun time mix of
stand-up comedy play a little ayg with
the crowd great way to introduce new
people to the show so grab your best gal
grab your best guy grab the bozos grab
the homies come on out and see the gang
oh yeah we're going to be in red bank
new jersey seattle portland kansas city
springfield st louis nashville but then
we're going to indianapolis ticket links
are in the description get them we'll
see you there welcome to another
exciting edition of
are you garbage the show where you find
out if your favorite comedians are
classy individuals or absolute trash
now here are your hosts kevin ryan and h
foley
hey
everybody out there and welcome back to
everybody's favorite new podcast this is
are you garbage oh yeah little show we
sit down with your favorite comedians
and we find it at the growth to be
classy but they're just a big old piece
of trash
i'm your host age foley coming at you on
a beautiful day we're down here at aunt
toddy's basement she's upstairs on the
couch sound to sleep mm-hmm eight bloody
mary's at brunch he'll do that to ya
okay my co-host is coming at you from
across the table it's a family episode
we're circling the wagons this week just
the homies the bozos and the squad kj
kevin james ryan hey gang thanks for
tuning in as always please make sure you
review subscribe on itunes currently
number 16 in the charts yikes uh full
video available on youtube typically in
4k and those numbers are true the roof
cooking nice and obviously uh my
personal
favorite website i know it's your
favorite website dave bonds most of our
family's favorite website get a print
get a pen and paper uh-huh real quick
write this down patreon.com
r u garbage sign up for a bajillion
hours of content they got it all there
it's cooking baby get hard feelings ayg
live streams the whole [__] nine do
it man we got the [__] merch over
there cooking virgil we got a bunch of
teas on sale all the links are in the
description we do a really easy peasy
for you not to mention
got that next [__] run of the middle
class famous tour coming up listen
the first show back we're taking about a
month and a half off first show back is
in red bank new jersey theater and is
about to sell out small theater not the
main one
it's about to sell out get your
[__] new jersey surrounding
area get your [__] tickets that show
will sell out very very soon yeah come
see us we love it and having a nice
quick shout out to our producer
extraordinaire the magic man makes us
all look good give it up for toby
mcmullen ladies and gentlemen what's up
dudes
jump the gun i know he you [__] you
throw a spike strip down real quick on
yourself
i feel like we got a pretty good give
and take here now that pass this guy was
no look pass it into the front row
[__] zigging when you shoot a zag
you're gonna be the one on the
highlights launching it not me i'm
sitting back [__] hanging out with
the offensive line you should have
caught it i don't know
um i apologize
i got something on my mind i you said
you came in you were a little you know
you're like i talked to you you were all
[__] on a tough a tiff we just we
just got back from detroit from
pittsburgh from buffalo shows were all
[__] amazing shout out to everybody
that came to the show to the earth
[Laughter]
come back i got black long what are we
doing [__] salt of the earth man i
loved everything they were [__]
just fun [__] shoes that detroit's
all right i'll tell you that you were
technically in ferndale yeah ferndale's
okay too not gonna lie
you got that detroit style pizza out
there it's got a bunch of psychedelic
mushrooms on it apparently shout out to
the magic bag and i'm not talking about
the venue i'm not talking about the
theater either trying to get us [__]
hemmed up at tsa an eighth a quarter
[__]
some of the fans are coming a little
[__] heavy hey boston george relax
we gotta fly in the morning
people are like where are you on my
u-haul full of dank i'm like jesus
christ oh where was that where we got
those two [__] buds
that was in buffalo because we were
luckily driving the next day but then
i'm riding dirty [__] crossing the
state lines you're gonna get the kids
jammed up god damn that [__] stunk
the whole joint up i thought we had
skunks trying to [__] call the
exterminator
however we have a [__] wonderful
[__] trip
we get back you take off [__] t-bone
hops in his uber i take me and tommy we
jump into uber yeah i'm sitting there
you know let's catch up on some things i
look at my phone let's check the credit
card check this check that i go and
check the old navy federal account
the savings account okay negative
67 cents
who claimed who fleeced you someone went
in and [__] i had [__] a jihads in
there not to be bragging
and a wave
of panic
goes over my body that i i started
sweating like cold sweats came out of my
pores so i'm over eight grand that's all
i got i know i mean i don't have much
more but i'm just saying
it's also like it's here yeah what do
you mean somewhere it's like someone
broke in and took it out of the account
well you're wrong because they did
because i then but then it's all insured
i i'm aware of that but [__] psychos
don't [__] factor in i don't know how
long the insurance company's gonna wait
i don't know what that investigation is
gonna look like i don't know what else
they're gonna think geico shows up and
starts dusting for fingerprints what are
you talking about
idiot they just put it back in there i'm
getting questions the ic up to a hundred
grand i'm getting questioned by the
general in a small room exactly
where were you when you landed and
realized all your money was gone so
family's fortune of eight grand is gone
i then [__] make the next phone call
or then the phone goes straight to
[__] the head office paddy gets a
phone call all right
is this a joint account
it might be okay i was gonna that's
when you're it's insane to be like hey
someone stole eight grand let me call
mommy
call the bank call a cop call somebody
what the [__] your mom going to do
what you going to get to steal and
[__] start
start [__] looking for who did it
whose car we did yeah who's cleaning
who's cleaning money at the strip club
who's currently there's a dirt bag
somewhere burning bands so i call her
now the the shared savings account is
they started that when i was a kid and
they put like five bucks in there and it
was sat with five bucks and stole a
grand
talking about the long con hey we'll
give you five bucks for you for your
college [__] steal all your money
won't you make it nigerian prince moves
over here she's like [__] britney
spears is dead so i call her she's
crying she's in a panic and i'm like
what's going on and she's like uh she's
like i did something stupid and i'm like
well that sounds about right but let's
figure out what it is so i have a shared
savings account then they started as a
kid i use that as my savings account
turns out [__] patty got an email
from navy federal saying hey this charge
was put on your thing if it wasn't right
call call this number okay you never
call that number you go and you look and
see what the customer service number is
and you call it phishing scam
yeah this broad's got [__] three
hooks in here you kidding me alkaline
and synchro with you patty what are you
doing [__] nibbling on corn over
there throw a piece of hot dog in the
lake and all sudden batty pops up she's
an easy catch oh god so she [__]
calls this number and the scam is once
you call that number if you have a
mobile banking app on your phone it
opens it up they easily have access to
it sure cleaned out the whole family
the whole family we're done eight
thousand and four dollars they got
holy [__]
no so
she she realized at the second that she
did it called navy federal and was like
yo this that the other thing
they they tried they tried to took me
treasure
[Laughter]
raised a black flag
a couple of cannon fodder goes across
the bow
man so they caught it but what navy
federal does what do you mean they
caught it they did they tried to take
the money out but
a lot of times they'll a lot of times if
anything like that they'll the bank will
freeze it and be like this is suspicious
so that's what they did now they hold
that in limbo for like maybe two three
weeks really jam yeah yeah that's what
i'm talking about i don't got time for
that uh-huh i don't know if you got i
don't know if you got the same email i
got but my taxes are due [__] monday
i ain't too thrilled about it
i'm going back on the sheet with the
[__] foreign investor i got a way you
can make some money if you want
get one of them efficient phones
whatever the [__] it is
so they um they caught it they shut it
down she added triple a or security to
her [__] thing which she didn't have
like a ding dong and what they had done
is they had uh
they had created a new savings account
for me that i couldn't see in on my app
until i added it and they transferred
the money over there
so that so that did that say you you
were made whole you weren't i could have
scored a little more than that i don't
know if she took a shipping and handling
fee or what this broad's doing you need
to pack a heater but i'll tell you what
as soon as i [__] as soon as they
popped up on my app that it was in i
took it right there and threw it a
checking account
[__] closed the wall off i mean she's
family and all oh but at a certain point
it's every man for himself gotcha i was
like listen i don't want my name
attached to anything that she's doing
get her get her out of there get her off
the [__] lease stay that right now uh
but dude god damn man [__] what a way
to [__] end the trip i was freaking
the [__] out then my brother's got to
get involved because he helps her with
the finances smart guy handles
everything he's over there [__]
dealing with it it's [__] she's
crying she's screaming
ah man it doesn't [__] end
how trashy is that
phishing scam
does it get [__] any more garbage i
mean it happened no i mean it happens
all the [__] time who are these guys
by the way somalis i don't know no
that's the pirates that steal the boats
i don't know why i was thinking that
fishing pirates boats nautical theme
that's where i was working i'm the paddy
now
uh
yeah i don't know it's just it's [__]
hackers well i used to work at a law
firm that did a lot of
can we get these guys dude it's just
like what's the drone situation what do
we need to do here i used to get jammed
up a lot cause i'm you know at the end
of the day i'm a pretty lazy guy
so you would have to call
so a lot of times they would
hack your emails and we would we'd be
sending wire instructions all the time
yeah what are the you worked for rich
people what do these rich people do
what do you mean the bank always the
bank always replaces it really like 97
of the time yeah so what they would do
is they they would hack into your emails
and then watch the emails you would send
like they would target these like
law firms that are handling a lot of
money or the clients that they will have
a lot of money hack in
look at all of the
[Music]
like wire transfers and stuff
and then just mimic them
like you know cop and but they wouldn't
be like i need five million dollars they
would just go like with
what's in place of
like if you're sending 10 50 grand back
and forth they're not gonna be like give
me 10 million dollars you're gonna go
let me get 20 grand let me and they'll
just do it a bunch until they get
clipped and they're [__] you know on
some island or a basement or something i
don't know i don't really know who these
people are leaky [__] god
that's [__] scumbag [__]
at a certain point i'm [__] i'm
getting off the grid i'm getting rid of
everything go cash under a mattress i'm
going to bury it somewhere nah i'm not
going to leave it in there i'm going to
be able to dig it up what are you
talking about i'll do it you'll like
peel like
you're like steve buscemi and fargo yeah
you're going to put it under a rock in
the front yard just cause you're too
lazy to get a shovel a bunch of 20
sticking out and blow it up yeah that's
all right
now we get gold and bury it somewhere ah
that's good do ron swanson
plus you'll need that gold that
currently holy treasure after the
fallout uh yeah i'd go silver really
bang for your buck who you've been
talking to huh i know a couple of guys
that train precious metal the trade
precious metals kippy v over here i
don't know what's coming
yeah no i get it uh
yeah that's i mean that [__] happens
though they get everybody i don't like
it i don't i don't like that that's why
you don't you gotta tell these old
brawls you just don't [__] click on
anything or call no [__] million
times what are you talking about never
open anything that was exactly how the
conversation went by the way i think she
got it from both ends yeah from the emma
the bank was probably like what the [__]
you doing oh and then i'm calling i was
calling i was talking to a service rep
and she was talking to the service job
and the woman's like i take the lady
next to me she's talking to your mom on
the phone now i'm putting pound now i'm
talking about this like chemical bang
from seinfeld all over again
the bank burned ah dude um
but the foley's
if you [__] with the flock
everybody freaks out yeah oh my mom's
know better though my mom's facebook has
been hacked no less than 15 000 times
[__] did i framework with did you get a
friend with don't accept it don't accept
i'm like stop clicking on stuff unless
it's [__] you know mary paula or aunt
patty don't [__] open it up what are
you doing lady she's like well he seemed
like a nice guy he was looking for a
[__] knock it off stop sharing
people's opinions on january 6th
get in bed with the wrong people
it's all flags what the [__] i know it's
a lot of a lot of usa stuff getting
tossed around on that face oh man
jesus christ when's the last time you
opened facebook i open it uh today i
open it relatively regularly because i
am the admin to the facebook group we
got the squad over there that's what i
go over there for that's all i do
also gotta go with the gang uh yeah
that's the only reason i use it um but
also now shout out to big kev uh uh we
have like there's like four big caps in
our life one of the big kevs uh manages
that for us wow started it but let's get
into some other [__] questions
goddammit
episode guys when you join patreon uh
you get a chance to ask your garbage
question just the best way to do it
patreon gets the first crack at the
goddamn queues and we're working on a
bit of a backlog but we're getting
through it the fish are jumping on the
boat you know what i mean
it's good to see i love it we love it we
love it we love it this one's pretty
this is from richard it's a little
longer so stick with it please garbage
it's a question and then an explanation
is it garbage if your mom met your
stepdad while on vacation with your dad
my mom surprised my dad with a trip to
mexico and planned a bunch of excursions
he got sick the first day and was down
for the count for a couple of days my
mom still did the excursions because
they were paid for and one of them was
scuba diving the scoop and juice the
plot of a long cane polly what are you
talking about the scuba instructor ended
up being my step-dad a few years later
get the [__] was it hank zaria
you do
scuba he rolled up with that big dong
sticking out yeah he was a hot piece of
handsome now
[__] and he was already hank azaria was
already a [__] millionaire before you
even saw him on screen because he got
that simpsons oh yeah i mean compared to
the money hank's area has made from the
simpsons he could he could have five
million movies and i'll never amount to
the [__] money from the simpsons
still got that hog though huh whoo still
got deborah messing in the sack that was
that movie she was
something else
she was something else and then also
that jennifer aniston that she was at
her jennifer anna's dennis yeah she was
in that free spirit in that one too the
ferret the tango dancing the dirty
dancing
dude i'm [__] rock hard over here
man that movie talk about a sleeper
[__] killer philip seymour hoffman
that's great stiller alec baldwin
baldwin's the boss baldwin's the boss
what do you guys think hank azaria makes
for one episode of the simpsons oh
they still make them like they're still
going in and working and stuff like that
oh yeah okay so not isn't every word in
the english language is probably
recorded from him that they can just
like throw together so he doesn't even
have to go in think about it it's
probably the most recorded voice in the
history of
[__] cinnamon james earl jones maybe
i think they reported this area has been
on for 35 years dude doing every
character [__] darth vader bro have a
little respect
been to get 30 years on them
what vader yeah but they weren't there
was one that's true
what do we got i mean he said like four
words
what are you talking about [__] ain't
your dad
i don't know who the [__] this kid is
uh how much does he make a it's got to
be like a million dollars an episode not
that high five hundred thousand fully
fully dead 500 300 30 stacks of high
society seems low to be honest with you
300 racks an episode yeah i don't know 5
million a year or something probably i
mean how many episodes they do they do a
lot crank them out
it's hot in here oh it's cooking
schwitzy mcsvitzen already i like it um
maybe his mom is deborah messing maybe
you never know um that was a sexy movie
sexy movie this sounds like a sexy story
too i mean that's [__] up
he's laid up with a couple of bad
oysters
i know he's got
[__] travelers viruses she's not
blowing the tennis pro give me a [__]
break i had that one time in italy that
was stiller's fault though what if you
were laying on the beach with your lady
on your honeymoon and that [__] giant
noodle rolled up [__] hanging in
front of her face
and then would you ever be like oh you
wouldn't get on a [__] houseboat i'll
tell you that i'm gonna go take a nap
yeah you take the snake out for a ride
get the [__] out of here yeah yeah nah
no way get my piece of that where do you
think you're going honey
jesus yeah that's [__] that's [__]
up i don't know but love is love what do
you want you know i don't know hey tell
that to his old man what the [__]
guys walking around with sunburned and a
[__] broken heart he shouldn't have
had the [__] guacamole i don't know
what to
[__] still have his family together
so you get ordering clams in acapulco
they'll touch the sushi and hedonism
next time they're ripping and the
tearing okay let's talk about indochino
let's talk about not looking like a bozo
at your next high-class function your
next wedding it's [__] wedding season
right now you want to look your either
even if you got a hot date you really
want to razzle dazzle get yourself a
little indochina go over there get a
custom-made suit over there shirt do the
shirts do the jackets you get to
customize everything top shelf stuff
you look discount prices feel confident
enjoy whatever event you got without
worrying about how you look they were
lucky enough to send me a couple of
shirts and i got to tell you i wear them
when me and the lady go out
at affordable prices
it's easy uh
you go online you can do everything you
want bada bing bada boom they send it
all right to you every suit is made for
your exact measurements you can
customize every detail create a suit to
fit you uh your style perfectly with
options for fabrics lapel shape custom
monograms statement linings and more
that's real rich guy stuff you got a
good lining you catch you catch the
inside actually tell the difference
right yeah yeah what do you got on the
inside see attention to detail if you
got a big day coming up getting the
perfect look is no big deal with
indochino get 50 off any purchase of 399
or more by using promo code garbage at
indochino.com
that's 50 off 50 beans 50 cold hard
bucks
off any purchase of 3.99 or more at
indochino.com that's i-n-d-o-c-h-i-n-o
dot-com promo code garbage do it kip how
about that under-tech under attack how
about that under tech underwear gang you
don't want to be looking like a bozo out
there you want to feel good you want to
feel confident you got to have some
support here's the crazy thing under
tech is the only underwear on the market
that has been tested by special forces
huh you don't want the commies winning
do you
huh that's [__] here for the boys
yeah it's high quality material that's
antibacterial anti-pilling and moisture
wicking so you stay fresh and dry all
day long i wear them specifically i plan
our travel weeks and we're on a road i
plan my underwear usage i wear them on
the plane there you go cause you're in
there it's hot it's sweaty you got your
jeans on everything you got to be fresh
because when you land you might have
time to jump in a shower you know what i
mean you can't be all and that sweat
builds up between your ass and that
[__] leather seat on the plane
bueno uh under attack is durable ultra
light fade resistant and shrink
resistant here's the best part they're
almost 30 percent less than the
competition
get under attack.com that's
getundertaq.com get 20 off site wide
with the offer code garbage 20. once you
try these out you're going to throw your
old boxers out i'm telling you they are
a proper comfort game changer good stuff
and if this isn't enough for you if all
that we got more turkey what's pretty
much thanksgiving cause kippy's got one
in the oven jesus under attack donates a
portion of its profits to veteran run
organizations let's go that are actively
fighting human trafficking let's go what
are we doing let's get involved get
under attack.com that's
getunderattack.com
off offer code garbage 20 do it now back
to the show yeah
did you ever see that guy what it was
he's at hedonism it's like a real it's
like a guy you would expect to see at
hedonism and they're like hey what do
you you know how do you like it here why
do you come here goes the ripping and
the tearing the ripping in the tits
[__] so creepy
it used to be a very popular viral video
you might want to save this for uh
hard feelings or something but you would
mention to us it's well documented oh
yeah we can talk about it okay um i
thought we have but i could be wrong
completely no for you know for for the
listener out there uh kevin's parents
split up got remarried kevin's dad well
well well-known story got married in
vegas you went out to that but you got
to the bellagio i remember feeling like
[__] hot [__] at the bellagio just
when it opened i don't think george
clooney didn't even rob it yet
that's how new it was
you
i don't think you ever mentioned the
fact that well it came up you i was uh
there's a picture of me
wearing a t-shirt that says jamaica and
you were like why
is that a jamaica shirt you're wearing i
go yeah and you're like why are you
wearing a jamaica shirt and this is one
of those things my parents used to i go
my parents used to go to jamaica every
month i was also curious why you were
500 pounds at nine
it wasn't that big oh man no
not then i was that's that that's a just
a chubby you were over 200 there
six years old
they call him
la tortuga
holy [__]
[__] fat kid so you're like why where
did you get a jamaica shirt and my mom
and at the time my mom and my mom's boy
my now stepdad but before they were
married used to go all the time they
would go to sandals we go down to
sandals
you've had to have told them we talk
about sandals i know they're real she
kept it out of the file
no no no i'm sure we've talked about
this you know very in the early
iteration of the show they were going on
little vacations and stuff like that
yeah you gotta figure they were dating
oh that stinks i know
and denise used to be a good looking guy
i mean she still is but you know back in
her day did she ever come back with her
hair braided or anything like that
like a high school chick
she's she's got [__] jamaica shot
glasses on the mantel and stuff
that was it feedback what a belly button
ring every every girl came home with
like you know [__] shot glasses and
came over a little more than that
um getting it in down there
very nice small intimate setting
uh and i thought it was clay i mean i
thought it was you know did they do you
remember if they had any sandals friends
there like people they met down there i
don't think so no i mean well yeah no it
wasn't the burkhart's from indiana or
something like that carol and tim are
going this year too
uh i know your mom real well [__] you me
my
i mean you sniff it around beat it wow
sandals wedding
get you also got to think the ti is
sandals trashy
mean
i don't know they got commercials and
[__]
yeah cause it's a good company yeah at
baseball games that's not good hey
they got you know they got billboards on
highways and [__] you don't see ritz
carlton doing that yeah they don't need
to if your family didn't go to the ritz
carlton you know you weren't on a plane
until you were 28 [__] judging my
international traveling family regarding
i'll give it to you it wasn't the nicest
establishment but it was an
establishment nonetheless free jet ski
ride with every room
free water scheme
it's got to be nice what's trashy i get
that it's not like and does hedonism
still exist that's his show that should
be the next patriarchy i'm just going to
say that we all go down there and [__]
each other
i used to hear hedonism
i think you're connecting hedonism and
the fine establishment of sandals resort
it's all sex romps what do we do it is
it's all black lights and [__]
butthole stuff no sandals i will argue
it's not classy it's nice it's not
trashy
i don't know but my mom start passing
out a limited shrimp what do you got
people jumping on the bed doing some
fishing over there uh okay what i would
say is that it's not lean and classy
because they're really hiding the price
on this thing that's classy you think
that's glass yeah that's like market
price
how much is the lobster that's the
classiest thing on a menu they don't
list that either
listen i come from classy crazy people
um
also too this is you know i know this is
i haven't told you this is this see what
a sandals package for two is for the
weekend
yeah and then i'll give you my credit
card
uh
my mod is a big big
big new big news on the denise front
mm-hmm she's going she's traveling to
europe okay like a month back to the old
country two two months going to italy
italy on a pirillo tour
they're going on a pirillo tour oh [__]
me and patty we're all going shout out
to the pirillos her i believe in my aunt
kate are going they riding around that
red bus or whatever they got over there
i think it's a boat i think it's a
little bit of a cruise a little bit of
uh you know you do every you do a day in
portofino a day in it you know you go
into a restaurant they have a deal set
up you get a bite of this a bite of that
ah i used to see they used to [__]
new york they would roll in
[__] 19 credit cards all set up bunch
of vouchers and [__]
but it's also
at the same time i mean this is a bit of
ask of us
what is
[__] on some sort of uh
international travel i feel like i i'm
all about the pirillo tours yeah
could never afford them guys sold too
it's also like we had that tan that's
how i want i don't want my mom [__]
you know ending up in like
some sort of taken situation
you know what i mean like she's got to
be with a group this is all broad she's
from [__] kensington philadelphia you
don't know what she's doing out there
they got us staying at a hostel yeah
exactly she won't be nice she don't know
nothing no whoa
yeah i had drop of sandals no it ain't
no 4.99 i'll tell you that much god shut
that up check the numbers on that
pirillo tour too yeah denise is starting
to spend a little cash now that they're
retired that wouldn't be a bad [__] i
think they made a bunch in bitcoin
that wouldn't be a bad patreon goal take
a nice perillo tour
well oh so my my uh the foreign investor
mm-hmm aka my wife
had a uh
european money yeah i had a suggestion
that one i think i would freak out one
of the
patreon goals
should be we take the queen mary to
england
my parents did that i know
get the [__] i just saw titanic that
ain't happening
i think i would proper lose my mind out
in the middle of the election
[__] out of here dude
what am i [__] gajepo gazepi get out
of here i'm not like a third class
passenger i'm down there with cold dust
on my face i'm down there with hans
get the [__] out of here
no way uh a weekend at sandals
everything is sold out by the way i mean
i'm telling you man everything's sold
out fancy where is there only one no
there's a bunch there's a bunch
of caribbean this is sandals jamaica
this is sandals jamaica montego bay sold
out till goddamn february 2023. whoa
but i think they used to do the grill
uh
it's
the lowest price is 33 hundy does that
include airfare uh no no airfare
that's this is club level if you want
the butler villa they were not springing
for that
they were probably doing their own
[__] laundry and [__] to save on the
price it'll run you it'll run you 4 100
if you want the butler villa with
balcony
that's an extra butler not come with a
that's how i that's what [__] pisses
me off about that [__]
yeah i told you it's
i get that it's
optical oh this is for a weekend yeah
four days think about that friday
through monday you leave monday you go
to jamaica
for four days is that worth it i've
never been to jamaica i don't know yeah
you have no i haven't you [__] said
you you were at the wedding i wasn't at
the wedding you weren't at the wedding
well we didn't go
what
no
how'd you get the t-shirt they brought
it back it was a souvenir that's what
she brought back
some bozo and a t-shirt i kind of caught
that i got a step i got a second i gotta
[__] step that into hot tea
but i wore swimming on the beat
my mom went down to jamaica to find a
new boo and all i got was a shitty
t-shirt they were big on
yeah big i think it was my stepdad
didn't he's a hillbilly like he's proper
like woods guy wears cowboy boots hat
he don't think they're puffing the chiba
down here no he's no i know for a fact
he is not a fan um
okie from muskoka you don't [__] with it
yeah he's real old-school
um
i did now this makes sense all right
hold on this is now my he doesn't know
anything about international travel at
the time he's more well-trained he
didn't get invited to the wedding was it
discussed or anything
what did she say
hey listen you're not coming to the
wedding did they elope
no which what does that exactly mean you
just leave without telling anybody i
thought that it's like when the dad's
looking for you or something like that
what you elope
like i guess from like you know like the
old west yeah you like run out of town
and go to the next village and yeah
chapel run away secretly in order to get
married yeah
but did they say we're going to jamaica
to get married yeah it's also different
they were together for this i told them
they were running a wawa real quick
can you get me a shorty
[Laughter]
sitting there waiting
no fat bastard maybe
[Laughter]
i'm trying to call her eat some barbecue
chips too
hey glee glorp
um
[Music]
they well they were it was it's
different they were together same with
my dad they were together for [__]
nine years my dad had my dad had a kid
with her like i had like a four-year-old
brother when he got the invite to the
wedding at least sure
uh
yeah no i don't even remember them
telling me they were going to go get
married i don't remember anything
i was just like yeah i figured he's been
living here for six years you know what
i mean what i thought you were married
[__] getting that will what are you
doing
[__]
we're [__] exposed over here lady
you've been sleeping in the same bedroom
this whole time description
all right sandals all right we're going
to get married there's 20 bucks on the
counter for pizza yeah
probably well no i guess i would do i
would just go stay with my dad bought
you four bags of dinner rolls we'll see
in a couple of weeks
fat little [__] shout out to the dr
don't drink all the slim fast
[Laughter]
well there you go that's a great
question um sorry that happened
to the dad that's that's a tough look he
might have been looking for an out you
know what i mean he might have been like
yo go hang out with that hot [__]
crazy scuba instructor too
or maybe this guy just pulled the wool
over her eyes and he's he was just
watching along came polly you know and
just pass it off as his story
uh this one's from patrick have you ever
slept in a bed that someone died in
i can't say i knowingly have
you know what i mean
i would [__]
freak the [__] out if i found that out
yeah i know i mean i know a lot of
people have written in or whatever
mentioned or tweeted that like that's
how they got their mattress that's that
like banana died and they took their
nana's mattress what the [__]
man you have to really like i'll see you
you have to be some different kind of
atheist like to be like there's no
spiritual nothing there's nothing out
there to sleep in a dead woman's bed oh
that's you have to really
be
i'm not religious
i'm also
i hedge my you know
you're superstitious super yeah that's
just something you don't do you don't
mow another man's lawn you don't sleep
in a dead guy's bed
who are you kenny rogers jesus
yeah [__] that dude no way this guy was
walking around in a dead man's boots
yeah that's another thing you don't wear
you wear dead guys clothes i do yeah
i did i do yeah i do whoa okay
jesus you had a conversation with
yourself for a minute there
well i was i was thinking i wore them
you did until it didn't fit yeah but i
did when they were alive i would get i
would get hand-me-downs from my oh
that's a little different yeah i have a
i have a pair of my uncle mike shorts
that i that i always wear all the time
mm-hmm which they say that that was
really doing is
doing his estate real well paying pain
in a dead guy's pants
ah the most comfortable
man's trousers
easy decks uh this is how weird i am i'm
just oddly superstitious so um
a family member passed away let you know
two years ago or so and they were
cleaning out his house this was probably
last year
and uh
we go over he had a pool so we went over
to use the pool
uh
and then
they're like oh go in you know see if
there's a bunch of [__] that we're
getting rid of or donating or whatever
okay go see if there's anything you want
and right away i don't want to go in the
house that that gives me [__]
he be gb he didn't even die there but
i'm still going
he's in there he's taking a couple laps
yeah seeing who showed up huh yeah
see who's see who's trying to nick the
china so i'm like nah i'm not [__]
with it and then uh
my wife was like oh let's go take a look
and she took two like
nice
like not champagne flute like nice
you're a girl yeah like grave robin
jesus christ
[__] pulling rings off the casket
what the [__]
you gotta be kidding me i'm doing his
shirt to get through his chains dude so
there's so she takes two of them this
wasn't the day that he passed away
literally a year oh it's been
a year later it wasn't like you had the
party after the funeral back at the
house and it was like all right take
what you want no but some family members
did do that they went in and really like
they were like taking they were like
taking food and stuff
yeah it's it's it's a wonky setup they
were taking eating a dead man's food
that's are you kidding
me forever they were taking like
cases of like what like drinks and stuff
how to just get out of the garage
i swear to get supposed to burn all that
[__] how's he gonna get the valhalla
so
there's
yeah do foleys do viking funerals in
above ground pools is that the standard
burial procedure on the bed right so you
never have the opportunity to sleep
through the mattress on fire in the pool
we cut all our clothes right before we
die
i don't want nobody wearing my shirt in
a ceremony you just light a scene and
let it burn down then that goes up
they put a sing in his mouth cover him
in kerosene
stick a couple roman cantals in his
mouth for the kids
i wouldn't mind a viking funeral i'll be
honest with you i don't know how you
would pull that off probably not allowed
to do that
i think it's certain international
waters probably yeah yeah and i think
it's certain do it on the queen mary on
the third day
stop me dump me over like osama bin
laden [__] keep it moving jesus i've
been on record that i want to irish wake
up i want to be on the pool table in an
irish pub somewhere i'm not coming to
that nuts
eating sliders off your forehead
covering your titties
to fly my topless i would have a shirt
on probably my jamaican shirt
[Laughter]
two quarters over your eyes get the [__]
out of here like dibby mcflynn you gotta
pay the [__] energy the sandman pay the
boat man to get you crosstalk that's
what i'm saying you're stealing a guy's
food and [__] like that i didn't take
eddie hold on i've gotta have something
to trade with saint peter unless he's on
the naughty list so
uh case aquafina get you into heaven my
wife takes two
glasses like nice i don't know what you
know not wine glass like uh
probably waterford crystal not they
weren't wonderful but like an old school
like waterford crystal style you might
say something you mentioned waterford
crystal to a dirt bag holy [__] that's
what i got so my mom got us for our
wedding oh whatever they gotta get water
for christmas oh they that's right
any irish dirt bag has some waterford
crystal in the dining room like hidden
that's the crystal kip let's talk about
upside upside up let's talk about the
crazy inflation that's going on let's
talk about what you're dropping at the
gas tank what you're dropping on dinner
what you're dropping here what you're
dropping everything's going up the price
everything's going up you can't afford
it you got to wet your beak a little bit
that's right and that's why you gotta
get upside down
uh with every purchase i'm earning cash
back thanks to upside cash back it's
easy peasy mean a big man did it you
three you log in it links to everything
so when you spend money bada bing bada
boom yeah we're not talking about
getting a five back when you buy
batteries talk about putting a little
something away for a rainy day yeah you
can check in at the business pay as
usual with a credit or debit card and
get paid in comparison to credit card
rewards or loyalty programs you can earn
three times more cash back with uh side
cash out at any time to your bank
account paypal or an e-gift card
amazon and other brands
you choose you choose uh it's easy-peasy
upside users are earning more than a
million dollars every week jesus
that's probably why they have a 4.8 star
rating in the app store that's pretty
good 2.8 download free the free upside
app and use promo code garbage to get
five dollars or more cash back on your
first purchase of ten dollars or more
that's five dollars or more cash back
on your first purchase of ten dollars or
more using promo code garbage one more
time promo code garbage do it now back
to the show back to the show i remember
when china cabinets were a big deal i
don't know if they still are we have
like three of them you do yeah but yours
is mixed in yours is like a trophy store
it's like a case at the pawn stars it's
all different kind of like there's a
musket in there
[Music]
signed picture elvis
no yours is mix and match but i remember
being a little kid there was you know we
had a dining room there was a china
cabinet with the stuff that whoever gave
it to them for
their wedding was in there and then
there was nice silverware somewhere that
we were never allowed to use
they probably hawked that [__] i don't
know whatever happened to it yeah so
hold on so we have two glasses
that my wife took and brought home that
i refuse
to use i if dude i'll drink out of the
toilet if that's the last taking a sip
of that and a bird hits the window
all of a sudden there's a cat in my
apartment
dude i'm burning the whole place down
dude i don't [__] father mahoney on
the phone i don't [__] touch him i
don't i won't play
nothing
especially crystal people's people's
essence gets caught and things like that
has [__] spiritual properties
i don't [__] with it you hear that you
hear them cheers in themselves
the answer to the look
he's got to push it always one more time
answer to the what to the legality of
the viking funeral
probably the one of the all-time ayg
googles here is it
is it google to have a viking funeral in
new york state well it sort of is it's
you have to be three nautical miles from
shores and beaches
and then you can cremate whatever you
want yeah you'd probably argue it's like
i'm sure you can argue it's religious i
don't want to be i don't want to be out
there in the chop
you know what i mean well you don't also
you don't want to have the tide pushing
you back in either
[__]
some kid on the beach eating a fudgy
wudgy yeah somebody's skim boards and
hits you
[__] ruin you ruin a goddamn family's
trip to [__] wild
that's where you want to be you want to
be three miles out a little privacy
yeah
light me up
i want to really cook too
i don't want to feel anything when the
[__] crabs are nibbling at me down
here yeah
when i go throw me on the traeger yeah
i mean all that lard on you you'll go up
like [__] chernobyl
low and slow baby low and slow
let the juices simmer
a little apple cider spray every once in
a while every couple hours
[__] shout out to it
oh that's great um all right let's don't
sleep hunt dude yeah don't do that i
don't do any i don't touch anything from
a dead guy hit a helix
maybe not this week but
in future weeks hit a helix at some
point um
let's see
all right this one's from dave
is it
trash to have a makeshift ashtray in the
car
yeah okay cup
any ashtray in the car even the ones
they make do you put in the cup holder
you're gross like the world listen i'm
not a big litterer i don't litter a
whole bunch but when it comes to sig
butts the birds will eat it you know
what i mean just [__] launch them out
the window which i don't think is good
for them
uh i wonder how many cigarette butts are
floating around on this planet oh it's
gotta be trillions
i don't know
i mean it's gotta be trillions trillions
is a lot
i mean a lot of heaters how many can you
see how many sigs are sold a year
in
this
continental united states yeah
continental you know i think each pack
is 20.
a lot of people do 20 a day
202.9 billion units a year yeah those
are packs
no no those are individual six are you
sure units their units would be yeah
units would be a pack
but there's only no that can't be that's
got to be individual six 330 million
means everybody's cranking [__] there
was 300 billion bernies a day there was
300 million lucy's sold in the united
states last year
um yeah my buddy justin used to do that
he bought like you know he thought it
was like cool he like went to you
in the
car wash they'll have like
it's like a coffee mug kind of with a
hole in it i get caught up in that
[__] night when i'm doing a little
[__] window shopping at the car wash
i know think you need this think you
need a little stp sdp
in the back seat the most biggest piece
of [__] i ever felt i was at the [__]
usa car wash or whatever
or sparkles one of i forget what it was
lunch
i got a hell of a [__] meatball sub
in there and uh
i go in and i buy something like that
i'm like walk you're looking for
something yeah smells good in there so i
buy it and on the receipt
it doesn't have like air freshener and
you know
phone charger they were labeled as
impulse buys and i was like i feel like
the biggest [__] rube you [__] got
me dead the rice and then you rub my
face in it like an [__] now i feel
like the biggest i refuse to buy stuff
at a [__] car wash just because i'm
like you know you got me your [__]
[__] [__] throw it in my face it
said impulse buy on it enjoy your
garfield windows sticker loser exactly
i might as well be like hey we caught
another one that was that that was
always a big sign when you saw that
stuffed garfield stuck to the window
we would never oh
good lord
i pick it yeah
more of a calendar picture everybody had
one of those in like some sort of church
group or something i i had a member i
remember this when we were on the road i
wanted to ask you guys did you ever have
the blinds for the car window that's
suction cup to the inside
no they that's for kids and [__] like
that
having kids now they have them where
they when they go up in the back seat no
we never had anything
ever yeah we weren't allowed we were
like you oh yeah you did as a kid made
me feel presidential yeah it does make
you feel nice i've gotten like a nice
uber where you've rolled down the window
doing this
it does make you feel real [__] nice
we had those curtains in that in in the
uber that we had those are real nice
those keep the telephoto lenses out yeah
do your key bumps back there all right
not a bad time keep the press out of
there um
[Music]
that's where bieber does his business
all right this one uh this is from
blaine is a garbage take two clean
towels home from the gym use them to
shower then bring them back to the gym
so you don't have to wash the towel
jesus that's
still i i mean it's trashy to steal a
towel but i i'm with him no i'm all for
it but it's trashy i'm on it
you're stealing sure a towels that
hundreds if not thousands of men have
wiped used in their ass cracks
uh-huh
you're taking them home
using them that's fine i can look the
other way but then to take the dirty
laundry back to the [__] gym
that's crazy that's why it's like
returning the scene of a crime
well you were was your mom or a rag
person
would things become rags or t-shirts
okay still t-shirts yeah
snip it right off you
yeah it's like a gunshot i think we had
an old we had an old cleaning lady
t-shirts you do towels
t-shirts yeah that's fabrics ask me one
more time that fabric's not going to
work together i'm telling you this get
your buns out your butter stains out of
the carpet or whatever they're using a
rag for yeah like surfaces not carpet
t-shirts huh patty always did towels
that she stole from the gym
uh yeah no
it was this um
old cleaning lady we had esther
which was weird she would like yell at
us and stuff it was like she like
came and
ran the house when my mom went back to
work it was single you know after the
divorce mrs doubtfire
yeah a little bit i guess you're just
like
hello
he's got a bernie winston out of his
mouth um
my dad was a marlboro man my stepdad
winston guy cowboy race cars
talladega winston's
winston's were all right softpack back
in the day still
softies
i didn't know they still made them
yeah that's good maybe not now but for
the longest time if you're a soft pack
guy you've killed people
right i mean you're psycho yeah you're
it's uh you play by your own rules i
feel softback guys that would say the
one time he was laying down smoking a
cig on the couch did i ever tell you
this story and
he was like lit it was like laying down
my mom used to go crazy i only used to
let him smoke in the house and she
didn't smoke like he was just smoking
the house
um
and we were like i remember being like
see if you can
smoke the whole thing without ashing it
and he was like all right you know so i
mean dude i remember he was like laying
down he got like almost all the way down
and then finally structurally you know
the integrity gets compromised that is
the most dirtbag
family bonding moment
get your cherry
some of the fonder moments of me and my
stepdad and he definitely did have his
cowboy boots on the couch mom you know
he's pretty cool yeah yeah we can't find
the jenga but we got a game we could
play
yeah it was big
gotta love it play ripping heaters
it's like pie in the face
hey you got the ash on you
move two spaces back
lit the wrong end go to jail you get
lung cancer
uh this one's from gabriella 10 homie
never had a question read
is it trash to ask the restaurant if the
water is filtered
i would defer to you
and i got to be honest i'm not really
sure the difference between like tap
still filtered i don't know any of that
no sparkling and everything else still
okay if somebody says sparking or still
that implies do you want a bottle of
sparkling or a bottle of still water
that's going to come from a third party
source
like a bottling place it's going to be
bottled somewhere else and it's going to
be the the source of the water is going
to be some spring or whatever the [__]
it is this is still water
uh
that's a bottle of water it's not it's
glass you said it's a all right so it's
a glass bottle not from the fall i don't
think you know if you put some bread and
olive oil on the table then it's still
water okay until i see some apps it's
just a bottle of [__] okay niagara
okay tell you that no that
you're not sure that is still water yes
that is still water there's no bubbles
in it technically that's still water yes
it is
but i wouldn't refer to it you used to
be a waiter for i would years if
somebody asked for still water i
wouldn't bring him a [__] bottle of
pure life like a dirt ball says niagara
whatever we're doing better you bring
him a nice bottle of aqua penna pop it
open [__] pour it
check the broad out see what she's like
keep it moving
okay tap water is just [__] water
from literally the dishwasher in the
back
nobody's filtering anything i always say
if you go to a restaurant they have
those the old wine bottles filled with
water and bring them to the table do not
[__] drink i understand but then
someone had a pretty good thing of like
and we just have to never clean them i
know but this is hold on hold on this is
what we used to say it's also like
how this was our logic for beer bongs
because like as a high school kid like
you do beer bongs and like ends up in a
trunk like you didn't have like proper
sanitary
rules and regulations for a beer bong as
a as a young teen
but so you just run some water through
it sure and if it doesn't come out with
the water it's not gonna come out with
the beer so if you fill it up and dump
it out and then fill it up again
see what i'm saying like it's cleaning
itself otherwise it's not getting in the
water i mean i just realized the flaw in
that logic yeah as i said people are
grabbing different people grabbing the
bottle food this that the other thing
the waiter's on coke it's [__] it's
all he's picking his nose he's doing
gummies it's a whole thing you're the
waiter i pick up in there he's eating
your burger
checking out your broad
putting an extra tip on there when you
leave yeah yeah no
um you can ask but
they're gonna lie to you
no one they don't have a separate why
would they have a separate thing that
they put money into to give you
something for free
mm-hmm you know what i'm saying yeah
now i'm with a brita what's a british
cost 19 bucks never change your filter
on that thing five years british are
right mm-hmm i think it's just cause
it's cold it's what is it yes that's
very yeah if it's in the fray if it
comes out of the fridge yeah yeah for
sure
well charcoal um
let's see
this is from thomas never had one red is
it garbage to buy a nice car but you
can't afford to live without a roommate
i would say in the world of maturity and
responsibility yeah probably
i don't think you're making the best
financial you want to have a nice house
and drive a corolla or you want to have
four roommates in a one bedroom and whip
around in the g wagon
i don't know i know it's tough i guess
it also depends on how old you are sure
a lot of times the roommate is like
i just want to have like if you're like
25 it's like [__] you want to live by
yourself you know what i mean never if
you're 25 you want to have a nice car
try to pick up some [__] broads or
guys whatever you're into whatever
you're doing
and you're like want to party with your
boys sure i'm i'm with that but even
that is tough because then they're like
hey jump in the g wagon we'll go back to
my place by the way keep the noise down
my roommates are sleeping yeah yeah or
come back to my place it's the party
house go back to my place at the party
house or
come back to my place just so you know
my buddy's down on his luck i let him
i'm letting him live with me for a
little while oh it's really his place
you've done that before
no
no i've never done that before
yeah i've probably done it probably done
it at your [__] parents house i've
lied a lot
that's what you're trying to get at i
might be lying right now
i'm telling my parents and my roommates
my parents are staying at my house yeah
uh no that's my chair that gets you up
the stairs
i do it for the bags really i travel a
lot
whose proof juice is this
get upstairs
um
all right this was from peach oh is it
garbage to hang dream catchers from the
rear view mirror my dad has one
on his baby blue crown vic
dream catchers are a tough look all
together i think if you get real ones
they've become commercialized i think if
you go to like a you know medicine man
or a chief or something like that and
get like a real one made up i could see
that but if you're buying one at the
gift shop and [__] scarsdale sure
that ain't catching [__]
i would argue none of them are catching
their unprotected what you're out there
unprotected yeah but i don't know about
dream catchers then could they catch all
the [__] dbgbs now you got a [__]
pandora's box of [__] that's what you
did it's like putting the stink eye or
what it's called the evil eye you put
that up facing out so no evil spirits
come
you're worried about drinking out of the
champagne flutes get a [__] dream
catcher and have a mimosa
you'd be all right that way
uh-uh
you're saying dream catchers if they
catch the spirits then you got all this
you got if you bump into it one of them
falls out yeah say it falls on a floor
in a dream shatter all over the [__]
next thing you got three scratch marks
down at your back punch a bunch of
[__] nightmares floating around
get the [__] out of here dude
in the car too it's like come on yeah
buddy you're driving come on ten and two
it's a green light let's go
um
dream catchers i remember the first time
seeing like some girl had that in
college or something like in a dorm
like
yikes i don't [__] with them this one's
from leo is a garbage to pick your nose
for 20 minutes straight while driving on
the highway [__] no what are you
supposed to get your work done that's
where most of the work gets done yeah i
would you know
got some stalactites under my seat i
know that much
man let them get all dry and crusty
[__] get a good cleaning in
that's where you do your business that
in the couch
most noses are picked on a couch or in a
car same with fingernails because you're
by yourself surely yeah mm-hmm
bite them off right behind the thing
yeah there would be some pretty cool
moments uh a cool moment is debatable
but
[Laughter]
there would be memorable problems with
you and your boogers
i would remember
being a kid laying in bed lights out
picking my nose right and then like just
[__]
just [__] sending it in the
stratosphere you know what i mean with a
[__] heavy bike flick pick your nose
in the dark
i can't do that again
i mean who can do that four times in a
row uh
and then but you would hear it hit the
wall if you could hear it hit the wall
yeah that was that was a [__] i was i
was hanging drywall that day drink a
little more water away yeah holy [__]
oh my god still or tap filtered this
guy's cracking windows with [__]
boogers
like a slingshot
um
nah all right this one's from tony uh
everest
took a broken
[Music]
item from home buy a new one at the
store switch the new one with the old
one and return it is damaged i know that
move yeah that's a real dirtbag move
home depot got real [__] keen to that
um
i've never done it
sir you bought a lamp this is a toaster
i've never done it but shout out to
[__] our boy sam rubinoff he does
he's he like is a he has like a phd
in like being able to use something then
package it back to normal like when he
opens stuff he'll use like a razor blade
and like i'll oh he really
she's he calls it re-pat or you know
re-gifting or something and yeah it's
pretty easy talk about oceans a lot it's
pretty sick it's pretty wild to see him
work around the holidays come january
5th gets the shrink wrap back on there
every day he's got like a
vacuum tightens it up
[Laughter]
some saran wrap in a blow dryer they
won't know the difference but i get some
people get awful not get off but that
people really enjoy going the extra mile
the extra mile being like i'm not going
to let this [__] corporation get my
1999 or what me i go i don't give a [__]
i'll i'll burn it at sea if i have to i
don't give a [__]
and it's out of laziness
yeah it's all laziness yeah i'm not
going back i'm usually never going back
i'm never going back i i also like bite
i don't know what the last time i
returned something was
just throw it out my wife i'll buy like
shoes i'll buy stuff online and it comes
and it doesn't fit or the shoes i don't
like them or whatever and then you have
to go to you have to pack it back up go
to a ups and send it back she'll do that
oh that's brutal if i could leave it at
the front door maybe you can you could
do that really yeah you can schedule
pickups and stuff i didn't know that uh
i just don't my wife's like she'll do it
she'll be like oh i got she's cause
that's how she shops she'll order like
50 things online and then send it back
and then get there try it on and then
send it back i can't wait like that no i
can't wait for it to all unfold
i had a couple of buzz lightyear toys
coming waiting on those at the front
door
sweet
oh i'm sorry
i don't pick boogers in the dark
i was a child and maybe sometimes as an
adult
i want to pick my nose turn the lights
out uh all right let's do one or two
more here this one's for a michael first
time question is it garbage if your
younger brother uses your old copenhagen
tins for street hockey practice pucks
nah that's sweet that's that kid's gonna
be a winner yeah
back in the day you were in a big hot
like street hockey or anything
oh yeah
yeah yeah watch i watch a lot of balls
go into a lot of gutters okay when it
came around a gym class i didn't hate it
i wasn't mad at that when we played when
we played hockey
that was cool more of a kickball man but
you know not bad sure kickball was all
right yeah strikeout and kickball that's
a tough look man there was always one
kid in front of the broads too man i
remember dude
my one boy just
had like the most inopportune
incidences like every time you know what
i mean we were like at the age where
kickball was like the last year would be
cool like
my seventh grade or something you know
when like you started getting interested
in girls and like
it was like girls versus boys or
something
and you still wanted to care and then
dude he my buddy went up and struck out
what like two strikes like two hardcore
whiffs and we're like dude
[__] you're really jamming us up over
here you're making the whole [__]
squad look bad
and then
it's going but you [__] like [__]
just get hit by it dude i know
step in front of it and he wanted to
like really be like i got it and he
[__] wound up
and he
dude he fell on his back shoe
[__] over the pit well what the [__]
is he peter sellers
yeah oh ouch real doofus moves
yeah real bad you got those situations i
remember at a certain point i realized
you can't try too hard in those
situations yeah you got to let it come
near a little bit you know it's a good
lesson and that is [__] dodgeball if
you try to be [__] too amped up in
dodgeball you look like an idiot end up
taking one of the face you got to play
it cool yeah hang back let it come to
you a little bit yeah but then that
happens sometimes you're the last man
standing
and you're going against a [__] you
know a team of five and they're all
[__] locked and loaded sealed team
six and you're a [__] 215 pound third
grader oh you probably didn't do well
i did all right yeah yeah i was yeah i
was all right in that all that kind of
stuff i was you know
fine solid average better than average
probably okay you know what i mean i got
the i won the golden ball a couple of
times
foley is the mvp once i imagine you play
dodgeball with a ball in one hand and a
five-year-old in the other that uses
your shield you got a nerd
[Music]
listen buddy you want to be on my team
stop being a [__] cincotti
take it for the team
get it in the face
you know it was all right though in gym
class badminton
yeah that was fun that was okay because
it was like silly enough to be like we
can be fun and silly and stupid but it's
pretty competitive i'll tell you it was
not fun when you go out there and you
see when they wage it
oh that [__]
they did our body mass index one day and
i was like some kid was i was like
we were like you was like you're coming
at me with a protractor what the [__]
dude you got a compass on your neck
you're like what the [__] dude
you were supposed to do it and then they
were like yeah normals whatever i don't
know five descent or whatever it was and
how mine was like 82. dude
they came at you in a radiation suit
this kid's off the charts
get out of here so i remember the one
kid was like i think your math like like
he couldn't comprehend that my number
was that high and he's like nah nah nah
your math's gotta be here i'm like dude
it's right let's just like shut the [__]
up sweep this under the rug and keep it
[__] moving
uh i hated that [__] we gotta wrap it up
gang all right gang we [__] love you
to death come see a live show as we said
tickets on sale right now the link is in
the description seattle
portland
all over
we're not talking [__] we know it's a
little bit ways out but they're you know
we're going to be moving some tickies so
if you want to get starting to move some
tickets and the shows you know are going
to start selling out so so get on board
while you can we love you and we'll see
you next week appreciate it peace